[Music]
in
gambling none news
oh nuns plural annunciate
submitted by the wizard of oz uh
500 000 from a catholic school to go
gambling
that's dope how many of these girls
where do they go
vegas two nuns they went to vegas you're
not hearing the real story though what's
the real story because they're doing
that so they could raise funds for the
catholic church so it's the robin hood
type of thing oh that's type
is it i already knew they were gonna do
that what's the story of robin hood
again he steals from the rich to give to
the poor
oh that's not the robin hood then it's
it's uh and he has sex with made marion
i don't know it's not a robin hood thing
because they're not stealing
but so they were getting 500 ml and they
said with the power of jesus
and i'm gonna turn this into five
[ __ ] billion or whatever
yep and then they try to come back but
then they lost at all were they in the
nun wardrobe
so these are all great questions
specifically like dude this is a movie
it's like sister act but then gamble it
should be hangover though
i was thinking about the horror movie
like the nun that just came out
i heard that wasn't even that good yeah
i heard it wasn't that great did you
watch it
i know you're not talking about sister
rack that [ __ ] was dope
even number two
i never watched it what oh you gotta
watch it
any movies in the 90s i feel like
bart's gotta do a we gotta do a [ __ ]
movie
night yeah i think this whole yeah yo
i'ma just send you one clip of this
little boy singing oh happy day
and that's what that's like that that
that christian catholic song that
everybody knew
even if they weren't like believers dude
and this dude was
good yeah he he killed it he had like a
true tenor voice so it was like super
[ __ ] high it's amazing but a lot of
those movies are blended
because there's like sister act [ __ ]
12 or some [ __ ] really i don't know but
there's a lot of
star jones he always throws me off at
the placement of the word [ __ ] when
joe throws in the word [ __ ] and he
always has like even very interesting
like sister act [ __ ] or like hotel
[ __ ] budapest it's like
you like finish off the term with the
word prior so then
you like the way i use [ __ ] so you're
calling him a poet
no but you know this is worthless
conversations like it's not usually used
but then the way i use it it's different
but then it works
i think it's it's in the way that you're
speaking in general it's almost like i
i bar [ __ ] with the word prior versus
a pause in between like the term
gate student again dude maybe maybe
that's his um
yeah yeah [ __ ] um his cussing flow
and conversation is kind of weird
i know dude it uh it doesn't follow is
that what you do with rap battles
when you attend them and stuff hey bro i
gotta say the word [ __ ]
perfect shitty is an exclamation point
at the end
anyway so these two nuns they worked at
st joseph school in redondo beach
oh dang that's close i think i've seen
that in our backyard dude so one of them
she was a principal
so it's principal sister mary margaret
cooper
teacher sister lana chang do they surf
she was the one that masterminded the
whole thing so this
is mary trooper what oh my god
she looks like a nun her last name is
krueger like freddy krueger
oh
they look like halloween masks dude she
looks white and asian at the same time
dude
that's crazy this is like the golden
nugget crowd it looks like
yeah that's the [ __ ] old vegas crowd
or maybe just hawaiian gardens down the
street for them
i feel like when asians get old they
start to look more more like
old white people yeah i thought she was
white i thought she looked like the
quaker oats dude for a second
like you've seen her on a dollar bill
[ __ ] dude so this is the school they
worked at they were
yeah i've seen that school before yeah
yeah so they were both best friends you
can't trust no none
she had worked there for 28 years and
the other one almost 20 years
so they were there for a minute and so
finally they got caught
what other [ __ ] have they been doing oh
so they've this isn't like a one-time
steal is like
been over a decade like oh slowly
they've been hustling they've been
killing it so
this um 500 000 figure is from what
auditors
have been able to trace in the past six
years of bank records and it doesn't
include
cash transactions so it could be a lot
more
wait over half a million in only six
years yeah that's a lot of [ __ ] money
because private school is expensive
well they're dope how do you how do you
go six years taking that money they were
stealing from
like the tuitions they're probably
stealing little by little so it's
very unnoticeable yeah but half a
million six years is
little by little yeah but it's about
what is that
is that 80 000 that's like 80 to 90 000.
well think about it right if you take
80 000 by however big the student body
is
that's little and how much for each
person or like twenty thousand a year
yeah there you go twenty thousand a year
for whatever thousand students that's a
lot of money i don't even know what to
do i mean the amount that they stole is
a lot
seven thousand dollars a month for the
last six
months yeah so so taking 7 000 from
if you take a little bit from all the
students which is like what skimming
really is like take a look a little bit
at a time
from a lot of people and they can do do
it through accounts too so like a lot of
these private schools they'll
have relationships with vendors like for
the kids so if they're gonna or they'll
just say they ordered a thousand
hamburgers
but they only maybe need 500 and they
could skim them that's another way too
yeah could be in food food supplies
there's like
high school hamburgers dude that [ __ ]
was nasty and good at the same time
which hamburgers it was the nastiest
ones that all steamed in a packet oh
those ones i mean the sponges
yup but if you add enough ketchup it's
pretty good that [ __ ] was
when i looked back on it that [ __ ] was
trash but i look forward to it all the
time and you get it with cheddar tater
tots and the crushed ice soda well my
school is way poor so i didn't get any
of that so thank you so just tater tots
and no ice no
what is a cheddar tater this is a
cheddar what is that a tater tot with
like chicken that's a gate program
[ __ ]
it's a good compliment though like it is
i've had way worse roasts here
we had steamed plastic hamburgers and
then the side dish was cut apples and
water
so cut apples wow that's something
we never got cut apples we just got a
[ __ ] apple no i cut it myself
uh you bought a knife hell yeah
how do you cut it they don't cut your
apples did they say this is the plastic
i don't eat apples straight up because
my mom has always cut them for me i
always eat it straight up dude it hurts
my teeth that's some first class [ __ ]
right here you want to hear some dirty
[ __ ]
[ __ ] out of here this is it uh so i i
was kind of like joe when i was younger
and i hated brushing my teeth too
uh i had to like that's really why you
got to flame this dude
nothing what to do that has nothing to
do with yourself
i know
yeah you could have totally said like so
i didn't like to brush my hair i know
you had to drag me down with you that's
what we do okay
the most random install it was so
unnecessary dude
i was like just oh tell me your story
you know how you like to not [ __ ]
brush your teeth when you're
when you're a kid i actually was wild
dude
you know how david has aids so i have
aids
it's like i wasn't ready
it was just like in hawaii when he was
chilling in the water and your mom came
up to it called
oh [ __ ] you're so fat and then she walks
away i'm like
what did i do you think that word what
the [ __ ] i'm just chilling here
that's what this will say [ __ ] i'm sorry
we'll continue your store you [ __ ]
so your teeth were trash i'm just glad
you know that i have another friend who
didn't brush their teeth thank you
you see you're not alone now it would
have helped when i said that
that you jumped in and said it's not
weird joe
i did that too but you left me in a dust
all alone
you gave me the courage now i can speak
up [ __ ] with you
hella got me though i was like i
laughing the whole time i
but then when i would bite into an apple
it would clean your teeth that's it
oh so you would get your teeth [ __ ]
to crush that
at the end why i don't know i just
remember it just was clean yeah did you
share
apple with anybody
oh my god you know how the apple turns
yellow after it's like you know the air
for a while
as soon as you bite it it turns yellow
[ __ ] up teeth
how would you do that i'm still on the
[ __ ] teeth brushing thing
dude okay all right so anyway so the way
these nuts got caught the way these nuns
got caught is that a family requested a
copy of a check made out to the school
and that's when the staff noticed that
it was made out to a different
bank so instead of
st james school it said saint james
convent
so that was like they created a
different company just to siphon money
out yeah that's so smart that's [ __ ]
genius
and that's normal here's the real
question were they were they
were they doing it for the power of god
like were they gambling
it gambling for the power of god they're
trying to buy more bibles
put more money into the yeah where they
taking money and then putting it back in
dude have you guys you guys seen nacho
libre he was wrestling for god
yeah was it like a natural leader i
think gambling different
from wrestling the information that i
have it doesn't say that they were
trying to to gamble all this money for
the school so i bet you they were you're
gambling too now huh
yep i'm gambling uh whatever i'm gonna
skip off somebody's tops i don't know
what that skim off somebody's top well
clearly i don't do these type of things
so i don't know the lingo all right i'm
gonna skim the tops off of some bodies
i love this what is the phrase what is
the phrase i have no idea top skin
you're gonna skim from the top okay
that's what it is all right i'm
gonna skim milk yeah i'll just come off
the stops
so the archdiocese of los angeles said
that it's not gonna seek criminal
charges and that they are gonna just
beat the [ __ ] out of them internally
going to just they're going to just
relocate them somewhere else no they
they retired last year so they don't
even work anymore they're retired oh
they
took apartment you know what happened
damn
i'm pretty sure they gave this is what
i'm hoping happened okay
okay that they gave it to the school and
they gave it to god that i
what i'm hoping as is nacho libre style
they did it
for the power of god yeah all it says is
they stole the money nobody ever said
that they
won anything true but these but they're
talking about vegas
yeah that they oh and then these that
both of these sisters they were known to
frequently take trips to vegas to like
other places but yeah vegas including
vegas like
what are their conversations like then
like when they took the money sister do
you want to indulge in sin tonight
oh and did they go up do you want to
send old
i feel like what they're gonna do is
just they're gonna whip themselves after
they steal the money and that's it you
know what like what's that what's that
da vinci
maybe yes da vinci code yeah that guy
that whipped himself yeah
he's paying penance maybe they get paid
really
really cheap and they were just saving
for their retirement
look up their salaries and then they're
not are they taken care of like don't
they live in a convent they don't have
to worry about anything
but they're that's their 401k for some
reason i want them to win
they're not touching kids you don't know
that oh that's the i don't think so
that's a t-shirt right there too i want
them to win they're not touching kids
and the question mark exclamation and
then on the back
you don't know that all right so here's
the deal breaker for me
okay if they were getting like [ __ ]
penthouses
with like a bunch of hookers and all
that stuff then why would they need
oh man hookers yeah or whatever whatever
they're into
like i'll be like then you're wasting
god's money but if they're doing this
and all the profits they brought it back
that's some robin hood [ __ ] dude that's
a movie right there yeah
that i could be like if it's for god you
could do whatever you want but they
could be a decent human being and do it
in a different like a car wash yeah i
know but then you wouldn't have movies
like natural library
yeah okay
[Music]
foreign